good afternoon i'm steve kresovich and i
serve as director
of the usaid feed the future innovation
lab for crop improvement
i'm also the moderator of this session
besides my overview we'll also have four
technical presentations given by key
leaders of the program
our innovation lab for crop improvement
was established in september of 2019.
it's a five-year program funded at the
base level of 25 million dollars
we soon will have additional associate
awards either funded by the bureau of
resilience and food security in
washington d.c or in-country programs
our partners for the innovation lab
include cornell
clemson colorado state
kansas state cultural practice and
macquarie university
compared to the scope and objectives of
many of the other feed the future
innovation labs our work is a bit
upstream with an emphasis on both
development of cutting edge
science and thoughtful delivery it also
is predominantly science and not
commodity based
our mission is to equip network
scientists and stakeholders with both
the intellectual and operational
resources to connect breeding efforts
with demand for better support of
smallholder farmers as well as an
attempt to reduce malnutrition and
hunger
our focus is to support efforts
addressing global food security in the
broadest context we were founded on the
development and deployment of scientific
insights and training
tools technologies and methods
our goal is to listen to
learn from and support national
agricultural research institutes as they
establish their own goals and drive
advancement to breed brazilian crop
varieties we believe that national
programs play
the central role in designing
innovations that prioritize
targets for their unique needs
and ultimately hope that this approach
will be more sustainable and reliable
the target crops of the innovation left
for crop improvement include
roots tubers and banana
legumes
excluding soybean and groundnut
all the types of millets and sorghum
we have a broad range of crop mandates
with this broad range of
responsibilities
many of our advances
ultimately will be crop independent
that is we hope to develop tools
technologies and methods for all
this slide highlights a recent summary
of our philosophy and activities to
emphasize the scope of our innovation
lab is broader than solely plant
breeding we take a transdisciplinary
systems oriented view for engagement
as noted previously we're also
grassroots driven that is the directors
of our international centers of
innovation which will be highlighted
subsequently are operational leaders of
the program
the breadth of our crop improvement
continuum addresses additional critical
engagements including resilience and
risk management
that can be as affected by climate or
economic conditions
we also strive for gender equity
and engagement
looking for inclusion
youth participation and ultimately
integrating all these priorities with
improved nutrition and food safety
beyond development and deployment of
scientific insights tools technologies
and methods
we're interested in advancing and
translating research into a public good
again we address key changes affecting
global food security
we strive for outputs and outcomes that
support broader societal priorities in
the 21st century
our approach and continuum of activities
are highlighted in this slide first
we've identified and established a
global network of experts these experts
come together to develop and deploy
scientific insights tools technologies
and methods
driven to the goals and objectives of
the regional leadership of the centers
of innovation
from there
we work with additional partners to
promote healthy crop improvement systems
so it's a systems approach not just
seeds or a new variety and ultimately
the goal is to improve food security
while prioritizing
engagement with a focus on gender youth
nutrition and resilience
it's not a stepwise progression feedback
occurs in and across all areas
regional leadership is at the core of
the program
the innovation lab for crop improvement
has established a global network we're
slightly less than two years old and
despite the pandemic we have
collaborators across the globe
note the groupings of complementary
participants on the right
they're objective leaders partners in
country a partnership committee made up
of key advisors
we're predominantly focused on latin
america and the caribbean
west africa and east africa
and at present people and or activities
of the innovation lab can be found in
approximately 15 countries
our innovation lab scientific support
team includes individuals with a breadth
of expertise and experiences
including agriculture life
computational and social sciences as
well as economics
many of you are familiar with or have
worked with people highlighted here
we start to translate scientific
advances into engagement and deployment
we assess success in outcomes
tangible outcomes
among these people
three leaders will make presentations in
the session including dr rubin dr
abraham and dr robins
our key anchor programs are highlighted
in this slide
we had intense competition for the
selection of our international centers
of innovation
over 100 letters of intent representing
about 30 countries were submitted
reviews were conducted by over 20
scientists with diverse background
the centers of innovation or three-year
investments with about one million
dollars in total funding and i'd like to
say a little bit about each of these
centers of innovation first of all
katya the
central american and caribbean crop
improvement alliance led by
roberto camacho and gail presswa
their focus will be on common bean
sorghum and sweet potato
in west africa
the crop improvement crop innovation in
west africa led by jedo kane
which will focus on sorghum pearl
millets
and copy
they also have partners in burkina faso
and nigeria
from there we move to uganda with scovia
atakini who works for nasseri in uganda
her center will focus on finger millets
and sorghums
and her partners include
tanzania
and kenya
and lastly
michael cipetta at longway university
will lead the center of innovation for
crop improvement for east and southern
africa with a focus being on copy
each center of innovation is unique but
together they create a complementary
team based on their opportunities and
challenges within their regions focused
crops
in research agricultural social and
economic systems
one of the directors of the centers of
innovation
geno kane will speak in this session as
well
looking to the future of the innovation
lab for crop improvement we intend to
continue our efforts to support centers
of innovation priorities
building intellectual and operational
capacities in country a continual
development and deployment of scientific
insights tools technologies and methods
we intend to integrate cross-cutting
themes
including gender
youth equity engagement resilience in
all our trainings of all aspects of our
programs and lastly i'd like to spend a
few minutes on identifying establishing
new partnerships
first of all we intend to link with
minority serving institutions in the
united states
and i'm pleased to announce the addition
of dr lavonne esters at purdue to lead
our initiative connecting the innovation
lab with minority serving institutions
we also intend to integrate with seed
systems delivery
i'm also pleased to announce the
addition of seed systems group
led by joe devries most recently having
worked with the alliance for green
revolution in africa to focus on seed
systems activities in haiti and senegal
we also intend to build collaboratively
with private sector partners this
engagement will include in-country focus
ranging from seed companies through
computational slash it groups
for more detailed information on our
innovation lab activities go to
ilc.cornell.edu
as session moderator i'd now like to
introduce our speakers first deborah
rubin co-director of cultural practices
llc
matthew abraham assistant director of
tata cornell institute for food and
agriculture at cornell
kelly robinson assistant professor in
the school of integrative plant sciences
the section of plant breeding and
genetics at cornell
and jedo kane group leader and molecular
biologist for isra of cross in senegal
they will make their presentations
you will
provide questions for the speakers in
the chat box and following all the
presentations we'll have a session where
all the questions are addressed
thanks for your time and i'm looking
forward to a great session thank you